est-ce que vous avez des astuces de
grand mère benjamin fait piquer par une
méduse
oui je les fais il faut se faire pipi ne
suis pas du tout ici
alors c'est complètement vrai derosa là
en fait lure et de l'urée en fait appel
les démangeaisons
voilà vous savez il faut vraiment faire
déjà fait pipi dessus oui absolument
série canal ou quoi bannon du public sur
la joue saga twilight fait pipi là et
peu apprêtée sociaux tu t'es pas fait
passer par une méduse
[Applaudissements]
tu prends des vacances ça va qu'est ce
qui fait aujourd'hui est à dire que
balade dans tout le monde tout le temps
à savoir que tu t'étais faire pipi
dessus c'est bon sinon tu es tranquille
au moins cher de la piqûre de dre
personne ne puisse rassurer jamais
personne ah oui maintenant cent des cas
moi j'ai un truc sympa c'est qu'on
trouve à éplucher un oignon souvent
leurs astuces de grand mère c'est moi ça
m'arrive tout le temps par guy baquer
chaque fois que je fais la cuisine déco
dernière fois hiroko voyez jamais fait
la cuisine doit il ou à oui mais je sais
rien faire mais il a des idées mais non
mais non non non non chacun sa
spécialité je fais des bisous à huy ou
bien les amis les croustibat en fait il
suffit de mettre hors jeu pas de cuisine
[Rires]
vous mettez de l'eau dans la bouche
plein la bouche pleine d'eau et vous
épluchez votre mieux et ça vous empêchez
pleurer ah ouais nan passe pour un con
on peut par la personne de parler vers
sa veux dire toute la journée les
horaires des ya des amis qui ne
parlaient à ton mec top c'est un wc ça
marche ou fabre et ça marche mais ça
marche assez bien que non mais c'est bon
elle voulait faire rouler ses amis ça
qui est plus cher d'union oomu crois
aussi on est perçu un nom personnes dans
l'eau voilà ou bien tu es plus choux
oignons avec et si l'on était plus chaud
nous avec un monde
un masque comme à des spécialistes de
londres quand tu veux pas pleurer dans
les enterrements
ouais tu entres en trouve légèrement la
bouche et s'accouplent le canal lacrymal
de voir comment tu veux non mais là on
n'est pas dans un enregistrement est
pris par l'émotion non mais c'est une
vraie cela m'a dit m'a fait aujourd'hui
théâtre à l'est et non mais là c'est bon
mais oui non mais des fois tu as un
discours à faire dans un bras et à une
oraison funèbre à faire et tout ça et où
la bouche est tu peux être pris part du
chemin depuis ses leçons gars lui c'est
le sauve est et des animations
d'enterrement
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti on fait des choix oui voilà
pour l'été pour parfois on souffre d' i
did non pas d'hydratation d'insolation
voilà ça peut être très dangereux donc
là c'est vraiment un conseil qui veut
peut-être me sauver des vies font
prendre une serviette comme ça on met la
serviette sur le verre et on pose à
l'envers je ne pas le faire mouiller on
pose le vert à l'envers sur la tête
comme ça je le fasse non si la
coopération je ne vois pas donne là je
peux le faire et petit nom lui by antho
pelvienne on sent que sur la tête et
cette chose et ça dégage à la chaleur et
ça fait bouillir quoi tu joues et menaça
revienne avant ça ne dégage la balle
vous le faire rapidement l koné samassa
dégage toi qui servent à rien et
personne rester comme ça
[Rires]
faire des tonneaux
ça toujours tu casses le vertueux bah ça
sans vis à vis des transferts de chaleur
complètement regardez c'est en train de
s'abîmer on a copié fait bien ça suffit
a bien c'est que j'ai mieux pour les
coups de soleil pas qui c'est quatre as
pas coûteux l'oeil vous prenez une
tomate
ouais c'est une tomate ça oui c'est une
tomate oui alors vous couper des fines
rondelles
ouais et frère tu crois que tu es dans
top chef vas-y alors est alors attendez
je sais que vous faire des fines
rondelles
ouais mais tu crois vraiment qu'on
allait vous on est là fines rondelles tu
imagines que tu un coup de soleil voilà
est-ce que vous imaginez deux minutes
chez vous les vacances et les imagine le
gac un coup de soleil qui s'est fait
preuve
[Rires]
et après que menad odeurs mais tu
m'aides à mozac non non non bon c'est
derrière avec des sommets très efficace
pour les coups de soleil banana partout
et donc tu mets ça tu mets ça et ça et
ça évite d'avoir des cloques et tout ça
d'accord pas super bien merci d'ailleurs
j'ai pas tout attention ne joue pas avec
la nourriture quel est le principe actif
de la tomate locale s lot et l'acidité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une très bonne pour le mal de tête
donc on s'est demandé pourquoi c'était
comme jean-mi quoi le mal de tête alors
vous prenez des plus de balles âme comme
ça vous fait ça vite fait avec
c'est pour faire apparaître tout le
magnésium tient à l'intérieur tout cas
prenez ça va mieux vous sinon nos
classes et bien voyez ça c'est
l'humidité vous la ressentez
ensuite vous mettez ça m'a tant elles
sont laissons vous prenez la deuxième
effet bien sortir la malaisienne la
banane mais aussi la nuque comme ca du
4e minute alors la banane dans la nuque
nous voulons nous implanter porte
écoutez bien à la balade c'est dans la
nuque d'accord oui trente minutes comme
ça commence à le manier âmes et là vous
appelez gabon paul manama la date exacte
mais je vais faire si mauvais médicament
s'est pas toujours bon pour la santé
merci à ces mots lui sur la tomate il
sur le banal
c
matthieu delormeau votre insu alors tout
ça n'a aucun intérêt si pour des trucs
futile bien sec ce cadre vous êtes chez
vous on est l'émission familiale
imaginez je parle aucun cas qui me
regardent jean-mi casta tous à vous ça
vous arrive pas et moi non plus vous
êtes très excité le problème le sexe ne
s'élève pas le sexe ne se lève pas
absolument le choc inter qu'il faut
faire l'audit
non content de vous prendre viagra est
tous dans cet énorme mais c'est pas bon
effectivement fautes en une heure vous
avez la tête comme ça pas pour ceux
conseillés par exemple vous savez ce que
vous faites une première grave
vous avez une banane ici bas d'un
contrat et mettez des tomates
oui alors oui alors quand vous prenez un
bien grand fayt sabato dilatateur donc
sa vie à dilater en fait que ça amène le
sens et ça vient dilater le centre
action faisait mal à la tête et ça
augmente et bien la place vous prenez
une cuillère par exemple d'harissa vous
êtes sachet de piment d'harissa quelque
chose de fort amady ba dilater pareil à
l'orangé faut pas l'amener à mx banon
mais pas sur le sexe non versés aux
normes et oui j'avais bien sûr pas
l'heure mais si vous voulez transformer
et là qu'est ce qui va se passer
évidemment avec citation égale qu'est ce
qui va se passer après l'accueil d'avis
après un quart d'heure pam
vous allez avoir un gigot non
[Rires]
c'est une fois c'était gênant parce que
vous prenez la douche après ouais et
même quand c'est fini vous n'êtes
toujours pas moi ou c'est que mange
toujours très épicé mots
[Rires]
ouais bah toujours voilà tout ce que
vous mangez une carte d'harissa si la
personne n'existe pas vous allez pas bon
d'être en zone aoc opérons par action si
si c'est mal ça va mais si tu donneras
ça à ton mari
cette astuce il est trés de son mari
leila il a déjà annoncé en tout cas
surtout paquet fou si en plus il faut
donner en semaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un truc plus simple ouais pour
l'érection
on sent le pro forma si vous achetez du
ceva vous allez juste à la pharmacie non
non vous a gêné duzan les plaques rouges
enfin une tablette
ah oui tu peux te la dit non non non non
vous mangez sa 48 heures avant avec un
pack qui tue mais j'm'en duzan là
pourquoi je sais c'est le meilleur
stimulant pour l'érection site imprime
sur ton air érectile ouais tu manges
duzan toute la journée tueur une forme
tu te dis c'est super ça c'est du sexe
et la cerise moi c'est sans compter
c'est mauvais pour la tension alors
formateurs ont passé ces ratios tu peux
le prendre en liquide musique et oui
madame oui alors moi j'ai un truc tout
simple pour la crème beauvau le visage
ah ouais la meilleure crème pour le
visage vous savez ce que c'est oui c'est
la crème pour les hémorroïdes en or aux
yeux non c'est absolument je vais avoir
une pas de culot
bien sûr
il passé
c'est exact ça si on vous dit vous avez
répété devant le culte certains
contenants et vous le faites vous je lui
fais c'est un ces chouettes maximus j'ai
une recette de grand mère pour avoir une
très bonne haleine on a tous des
problèmes d'haleine dans les pattes et
là on n'a pas tous les problèmes
franchement dit la vérité est ce que
sans citer la personne ouais
est-ce que vous avez déjà senti une
personne qui avait calé une mauvaise
haleine
un jour dans l'équipe aubenas tabac oui
oui oui non non non pas lui dont ils
sont dans nos chambres à part dont le
seul qui se tenait dans l'émission c'est
moi qui l'ait cela dit non parce que là
une bouche mon frère normal c'est son
capital face à son capital beauté
c'est comme si moi je ne l'avais pas là
je verrai ça vous allez en pharmacie ou
pas acheté une petite huile essentielle
de menthe que vous avez placée sous dans
notre île c'est là une scène violente à
chaud sur les talons quoi il faut lui
l'essentiel sous tp tu va présenter des
oui comme ça rentre dans le sang en
revanche chose à la voir cela l'est lui
brandissant la vente c'est magic
directement dans la bouche l'état ou
vois pas ce que lui l'essentiel ce n'est
pas forcément dans la bouche quoi donc
tu met à tuer d'une sûreté pièce à
l'elysée avant voilà épuisé l'essentiel
à une très belle rencontre était finie
et bien sous le bac c'est pas que je
vais voir si je lui ai dit si vous
essayez alors oui alors vous seriez vous
avez la hantise de quoi en priorité les
pieds non non non les microbes vous qui
faites un peu de télévision
les microbes c'est d'abord la lodyans la
voix enrouée une bronchite un truc qui
viennent vous terrassé vous pouvez plus
faire et est ce que vous allez prendre
du jus de betterave
ouais c'est maintenant porte quel siro
le chic d'étrave c'est un antiseptique à
la can ça adoucit sa n'en dort pas et on
va des vertus incroyables machines
vendues
ma grand mère mais c'est bon c'est bon
de damas fier de ça c'est vraiment très
bien passé au conseil vous apprendra par
exemple
rien aucun des malades attendu métrages
mettant preuve que quand tu es malade
ribéry ans malade bien sûr on est malade
qu'on n'a rien on peu d'épopée on n'est
pas obligé compromettez monde quand même
c'est quoi tout l'astuce algériens parce
qu'on m'avait dit clous de girofle quant
à mal aux dents faut mettre des clous de
girofle gmi clous de girofle j'ai fini à
2 heures du matin rue maubec chez toi
d'en rater
[Applaudissements]